so as you guys already know the Arctic's
2060 launched just a week or two ago and
it is arguably the best value archaic
card launch so far but despite that it
is by no means a budget or even
mid-level card coming in at three
hundred and fifty dollars as a result
many buyers even now our turn to attend
60 but there is what if a new 1660 t.i
which may be more wallet-friendly
so should you wait for that card instead
[Music]
welcome to Hari Saudis so before we move
any further make sure to keep in mind
that this is just a rumor it is from
video cards and they claim to have three
sources and I've gotten many things
right in the past but that doesn't
change the fact that this is just a
rumor so just make sure to keep that in
mind
starting off what type of performance
can you expect from this card well of
course a rumor is gtx 1660 TI is
supposed to have six gigabytes of gddr5
memory just like the Arctic's 2060 it's
supposed to be based on internal
architecture and have 1536 cuda cores to
put this in perspective the architects
2060s 1920 cuda cores the gtx 1060 has
1280 cuda cores and the gtx 1070 of also
has 9020 cuda cores so 1660 TI should be
a good amount better than a 1060 but not
quite on a level the 1070 so basically
this is designed to be a next 1080p 60
frames per second gaming card right now
the gtas 1060 is a perfect 1080p 60
frames per second maximum settings
graphics card along with the AMD rx 580
however recently as gator continuing to
get more complex the 10 succeed can't
handle 60 frames per second on all games
at maximum settings and that's where the
sixteen sixty TI would come in so this
card if it comes out will be the go to a
1080p graphics card for the next couple
of years so that's just about what type
performance you can expect from this
card but how much will it cost
well here's the thing this car is not
supposed to have great racing technology
and rate racing technology with a huge
component that was inflating our test
car
prices the Arctic's 2016 has great
trades technology and is a good amount
more powerful in this card and that
comes in at $350 so considering that the
new 1660 di should come at maximum of
$300 but hopefully $250 or we may see is
something like the gtx 1066 pure buy
card or the fairest addition costed $300
but third-party variants came in at $250
I actually think that this is the most
likely case noumic and Amazon actually
randomly have tend to turn our discounts
so you should be able to pick up this
card for a little less than $200 at 230
or 240 dollars
finally when can I expect to pick up
this card well she takes 1060 1070 in
1080 production is to help to several
months ago and at disappointed GTX 280s
intimated TI's are pretty much
non-existent or yet pay very high prices
to get one and as a result the GTX 1060
in 1070 are not far behind that and that
seems like the perfect time to long to
1660 TI as a replacement for the GTX 260
so you should be able to pick one of
these up in the next one to three months
if they truly are coming out so should
you wait for this car and buy this card
over the gtx 1066 by car well here's the
thing the GT of 1066 cuban card is still
a really really good card and since we
chose are trying to get ready for last
inventory you'll probably have a good
discounts on so if you can find a gtx
1066 Quebec car I had a very good
discount like a hundred and fifty to one
hundred and eighty dollars and you
really just care about performance per
dollar and I recommend going with that
card but if you would like to have some
more performance and wouldn't mind
having the newest thing then I
definitely recommend you guys wait for
this new card and in my opinion there is
a very good chance that this card
actually comes out because 1016 retires
almost out and what is the media are
going to do after gtx 960 runs out most
of envious consumers are mid-level
buyers and PS not just going to let you
take those buyers
so there's definitely going to be card
coming very soon to replace the gtx 960
whether that'll be that gtx 1660 TI or
gtx 2050 what
they would want to call it so in my
opinion if you're looking at buying gtx
1066 quebec card right now then you
should definitely consider waiting for
this new card coming out but that's just
what i think what do you guys think what
are your thoughts on this card and are
you going to be waiting for it
maybe you comment that down below also
if you guys like to forget and make sure
to drop a like and consider subscribing
if you like see more videos just like
this one but no then i'm Hari I'll see
you guys on the next one
[Music]